ultimate backhanded compliment coming at
you right here you ready here it is it's
better than the last one
[Music]
underworld blood wars so underworld
blood Wars continues the story of the
underworld franchise the franchise now
underworld started out vampires versus
likens likens being werewolves and
Selene played by Kate Beckinsale she's a
Death Dealers she's going against the
lichens and her people betray her so
she's going against them - all the while
she hazzard love interest fast forward
many movies later pretty much the same
thing - the love interest and in this
movie the new Lycan leader is looking
for her child axe everyone was really
looking for her child because her Bloods
gonna make super soldiers or something
like that so everyone wants a piece of
that thought however now here we are
vampires and werewolves and really
vampires versus vampires because there's
a lot of that - and that's what I'm
gonna say is cool and the actions going
down it's cool enough I was watching I
was like yeah it's cool action going
down in an action movie but nowadays
action movies when they have it yeah of
course it's gonna look cool not all of
it looks cool but a lot of it does look
cool but she's fighting Frankenstein's
monster from the trailer is like yeah
it's a pretty fun fight because people
are getting hit hard and people are
slamming into rocks and there you are
simplest part of my brains like yeah
cool really that's what the movie has
the movie also as many underworld movies
have in them is interesting lore with
very little power I'm not saying all the
underworld movies are terrible I'm
saying that all the underworld movies do
suffer from the fact that it's built on
such an interesting premise and that
premise never really has the payoff it
should given the premises you're
watching the movie there is that logic
part of the brain that starts opening up
like wait a minute that doesn't make any
sense you really have to beat that thing
down if you're gonna enjoy this when you
have such a big board I imagine would
get attention from governments and
people and agencies that never really
gets that attention you have to assume
that everybody in the world is a vampire
it's like the movie Daybreakers or
something if we don't exist in the movie
Daybreakers there's a big problem here
no one notices this [ __ ] go down and I
find that strange movie doesn't offer
anything new like if you're not on the
underworld train by now this is not
gonna be the one that brings you over if
you don't like the franchise this is
more of the same [ __ ] you didn't like
before vampires likens there are
traitorous vampires among the vampire
ranks so here we go and there is a
what in those movie where someone
becomes so Opie so overpower and they
never are used to the legs they could be
used flash syndrome this person comes in
and zipping around like the flash it's
like you could just end problems right
now don't do that because once you give
someone so much power they can't use it
in the movie or just choose not to use
it in the movie because the movie would
simply be over now also and this is the
glaring issue that there are arcs in
this movie that are interesting enough
that don't really matter because the
people they revolve around don't really
matter because the movie didn't actually
make them matter like someone's like
actually I'm gonna take charge now
because I meant to you don't care yeah
that sucks that you don't care but I'm
going to now oh yeah it was in the
audience like I do not give a [ __ ] about
you one of the most glaring things in
this movie is the way it wraps up it's
almost like there was 15 minutes to go
in the entirety of the movie then
someone came in was like guys bad news
we're out of budget so do a voiceover
and wrap it up all right now wrap it up
there was a voiceover and it wrapped
right up like the end of a Transformers
movie or some and it was really jarring
I'm really bagging on this movie more
than I thought I would the movie there's
a couple of scenes where you can see
potential as to how they could have
executed this thing there's some form of
great entertainment then you realize
that the best underworld movie is
actually the first underworld movie they
should probably let it go let's face it
the entire arc of where they were going
for the first set of underworld movies
is gone now it's a new thing so if they
don't want to reboot the underworld
movies guess what you actually did
reboot the underworld movies it's just
stuck in the same shitty loop you built
it into and so now it can't escape that
it would have been better just to scrap
it all and start over they didn't pull
the trigger on it so now we're slogging
through the mud some of that I gotta say
you're not gonna remember underworld
blood wars in t-minus one day I've
already forgotten alright guys so
underworld blood wars have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your favorite and least favorite
underworld movies whatever they're
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]